auf und bediene präsentiert von der
leyen für oliver länge tote weniger lang
weg sind ach wer wollte nicht schon mal
auswandern auswandern an einen ort der
noch platz bietet um endlich die großen
träume zu leben
letztes jahr haben wir menschen
begleitet welche die kleinräumige
schweiz verlassen hatten
angetrieben von ihrer großen liebe zu
tieren und zur natur da sind alexandra
und markus ruckstuhl sie zogen mit ihren
töchtern josephine und elena nach kanada
hier hat der vater eine anstellung als
farmarbeiter gefunden und mit den
hausgarten erfüllten sie sich den traum
einer eigenen kleinen fahren
diesen garten komplett wenn ich das
gerne
was ist die session daniel frauen das
geld ist knapp
töchterchen josephine leidet an einer
seltenen krankheit ponyreiten der eine
gute therapie auf der suche nach einem
selbstbestimmten leben wanderten miriam
thomann und hospiz je nach spanien aus
sie übernahmen einen reitbetrieb samt
gestüt an seiner seite der erfahrene aus
strenge geschäftspartner robert
[Musik]
die lehrlinge unterrichten zog
milliarden euro ausmachen
[Musik]
unter waren die tiger von remo müller
mit ihnen im gepäck wanderte er nach
deutschland zu seiner freundin aus sein
vorhaben hätte er in der schweiz nie
verwirklichen können den traum vom
eigenen tierpark dem wetter wenn so
schön ist ein schlaf sie meistens da
irgendwo im gebüsch und das ist ja das
schöne gerade deshalb so viel platz dass
autismus gesucht überhaupt ticket ist ja
alles gut bei dir das ist fein
so kommst du mit im deutschen welle fand
er den platz für das tiger quartett ab
und für seine ideen
sie ist schon hier oben drin ist alles
gut schon fertig und mit der
auswanderung kam ein weiteres glück dazu
bei der wärme ich da klebt ein bisschen
frisch also gehe ich nie fertig sie
eigentlich mit jedem training und so
soll jeder sind die tierbetreuung
zwischen toni und im notfall ist nach
oben und opa da das passt kleine zwerg
[Musik]
heute zählt der tierpark über 100
bewohner
doch angefangen hatte die geschichte mit
einem stillgelegten zu und einem umzug
der tiger von großer in st gallen nach
deutschland
alexandra tetz und renault müller
schauen zurück
[Musik]
dank seines unerschöpflichen
einfallsreichtums konnte er sich schon
einige träume erfüllen
[Musik]
ursprünglich ist herr koch nun klären
wie wir es bilde mit zirkus häftlinge
haben wir auch den kunst zum zirkusse
und so habe ich dann auch gemacht haben
aber dass koch eigentlich auch fahrer
gefunden wie die haben die wettbewerb
macht so die kochkunst nur ein dutzend
wieder erfolgreich hätte es natürlich
auch erfahrungen spaß machen seit elf
jahren arbeitet er als koch und als
tierpfleger im wald dazu an
winterabenden verwandelt sich das zu
restaurant in ein varieté mit galadinner
küchenchef remo ist verantwortlich für
das wohl von über 100 gästen
münchen
stelle
[Musik]
so hat er schon viele dinge gemacht habe
ich jeden dinge dangel digital und witz
verloren bei mir ganz ganz gut aber auch
daneben heute 70 jahre ganz große traum
in eigene tierpark und danach trifft und
für diesen traum ist remo bereit heimat
und vertrautes aufzugeben
einzig und allein seine lieblinge die
nimmt damit seine lieblinge das sind 4
sibirische tiger sie sollen dereinst die
große attraktion in seinem tierpark
werden
[Musik]
endlich ist es soweit es geht ans tiger
einpacken
irgendwie wird hier ist kandidatin die
wichtigen wenn man's ja ein kleines
stück fleisch kuranyi in die kiste
locken
er ist inzwischen gelöscht
nein
nach diesem besonderen tag ist auch
freundin alexandra in die schweiz
gereist
ich habe mich immer gewundert wie remo
so ruhig bleiben kann also ich glaube
ich war viel viel aufgeregter aber das
macht es wahrscheinlich auch aus wenn
man diesen tieren einfach lebt und
arbeitet je unsicherer die sind umso
relaxte musiker und sänger alles super
wenn ich vielleicht nicht gerade ideal
oder so aber wenn wir merken da wird
nervös oder da ist auch komisch dann
wird daraus viel stimmen also einfach
ruhe bewahrte und irgendwann klappt
zimmer also eine fischerei jetzt ist die
suppe dichtung
[Musik]
die tigers sind verpackt nur renault hat
seinen platz noch nicht gefunden
maria ich jetzt einfach mal fragen ob
ich das gemerkt aberglaube ist noch zwei
drei wochen also ich habe das habe ich
früher die macht dann einfach und
studieren jetzt viele links und rechts
um
ich glaube dass ich im moment wird
zwei jahre lang ist remo zwischen den
deutschen bell und der schweiz gependelt
nun bleibt er für immer da sein neues
zuhause ist ein stillgelegter tierpark
image ich weiß dass ich immer gedacht
habe die zeit geht nie um bis remo
endlich hier im park anzieht war einfach
so schön wenn der tag irgendwelche
eigentlich bräuchte remo absolute ruhe
aber es wimmelt von schaulustigen kommen
in wellen
das mobiliar somit sehen da sind leute
wie kommando so gab sein land eine
wirklich gute freunde sind
die kiste mit der 160 kilo schweren
tigerin rani wird als erste an der
öffnung zur tiger stellung angebracht
mit spannrahmen muss die kiste
festgezurrt werden
die tigerin könnte sonst die box einfach
weg schleudern
[Musik]
ob frauen ich fragen habe ich das im
fernsehen als richtiges gesagt
jetzt kommt die partie nur an die reihe
um wirklich ruhe zu haben schickt remo
die helfer weg und bleibt allein bei
timo
[Musik]
einzig freundin alexandra hart mit ihm
aus erst spät nach mitternacht springt
der letzten tiger in die stallung
situation dann auch irgendwie nicht
weggehen auch wenn ich jetzt nicht
direkt helfen konnte ich warte
eigentlich immer noch darauf dass er
irgendwann mal unruhig wird diese
geniale der spitze segen so langsam
unruhig eindruck wie wenn ich mal die
tische arbeiten der schweizer zog
schnell
schnell haben sich die raubkatzen in
ihrem neuen zuhause eingelebt das stroh
ist trocken und warm draußen ist es kalt
und nass und der ganze park eine
baustelle siebeneinhalb hektar groß ist
das gelände
die ziegen hat remo vom alten besitzer
übernahmen noch leben sie in einem
matschigen provisorien haymoz größter
stolz ist das neue außengehege für seine
großkatzen
das hat er selber entworfen er zeigt es
miriam einer ehemaligen arbeitskollegin
das narrative mondlandschaft am samstag
macht er doch die letzte sache jetzt wo
der schnee weg ist und nachher da wird
auch zeit denn hoffen
relativ schnell demontiert aber es ist
aller allerbeste ist das da oben also
denkens blick 3000 quadratmeter groß ist
das gelände mit wäldchen und
swimmingpool ein solches reicherte remo
seinen lieblingen in der alten heimat
nie bieten können
das vieh zum park oder nur das kleinste
mit einer bewilligung unmöglich also
hätte meine um entlang recht und der
schweiz hat man für das geld nicht im
malersaal familie
[Musik]
die huskies haben bereit sein
niegelnagelneue hegel und konnten als
erste ihr neues zuhause beziehen die
hunde hat alexandra aus verschiedenen
tierheimen geholt die tiertrainerin will
sie zu einem staaten schlittenhunde team
ausbilden und spaß bringen glaubt ihr
neunjähriger sohn platz aber das
vergessen
das gab uns heute am 10 niemand gefahren
wird das ging vergessen
der stall für die vier ziegen wir haben
wir dann morgen die heute ja die
brauchen dringend ihren stall gerade mal
gucken ob ich die telefonnummer finden
ja schön und hier ist alexandra teetz
von der villa tietz gbr
ja ich habe es mit kramer dafür ist dass
niemand da heute bis 17 uhr
weißt du was ich fahre jetzt einfach los
und holte es mit dem pferdeanhänger ab
der antrieb der wechsel sich immer so
ein bisschen höher
das ist das schöne wenn der eine sagt
war ich glaube nicht dass wir es packen
dann ist der andere völlig überzeugt
also das verleitet mir dass man jetzt
kommt es immer härter aber das ist nur
eine westerwelle kamen und zwischen
jesus sieht das irgendwann denkt im büro
haben glaubt beiden ihre arena steigen
zwei wochen bleiben ihm und den
großkatzen bis zur eröffnung
das ist im notfall schnell raus bin
nicht von außen schließen
[Musik]
gut dann machen wir auch keine ganze
denen schon öffnen
[Musik]
ok heikki gutes mädchen habe tim k
ok pinke pinke wie bravo hits bravo
dinka nur eine mag das spektakel nicht
mit ansehen
alexandra held es was nicht aus der
arena steht
ich war da wirklich relativ angespannt
aber inzwischen ist das nicht mehr so
also irgendwie hat sich das mit 61 zu
lesen gelegt weil es jeden tag so ist
sich viel näher dran bin als früher hat
das vorher nie so direkt mitgekriegt
jetzt kann ich dann schon öfter mal
einen blick reinwerfen das nicht mehr so
wie diese anspannung aber nicht dass
jetzt sehe dann weiß ich noch wie ich
mich da gefühlt hatte raich nicht ganz
so entspannt
drei tage vor eröffnung orkanartige böen
haben den tierpark fest im griff
das dach zusammen
eine sturmböe hat das dach vom großen
schuppen aufgerissen
warum jetzt das thema erzählt dem ding
stand kalte und genau jetzt oder ecke
dann gleich auch noch da fängt auch
schon ab da ist sein adels und draußen
noch mehr
nein des jahres ist macht uns mut
gemacht das neueste projekt
jetzt greifen die in unser sturm hält es
braucht ein mensch
das war ein moment wo ich gedacht habe
wir schaffen das nicht mehr rechtzeitig
mit meinen taschen und gewittern ist
oder jetzt ganz schlecht ist immer noch
verletzt worden
kuby war es lustig ist philippe suchet
aus der schweiz wollen die wenn der
dicke und so dass wenn es natürlich auch
sehr aber die frage dann immer und wenn
es dann ist es endlich soweit das rote
band darf nicht fehlen
[Musik]
so wirkt es so als hätten schlechtes
wetter mit harmlos letzter kraft ja aber
ein tag nach der eröffnung was schönes
trotz des schlechten wetters eine
deutsche fernsehstation filmt und der
bürgermeister ist auch da lieben familie
betz libéré müller meine damen und
herren ich freue mich ganz besonders
dass wir heute an diesem apriltag hier
sind ihr erlebnispark quell eröffnen
dürfen
das steigert unsere attraktivität als
region um kassel herum ungemein das
alles wäre nicht möglich gewesen wenn
wir all die helfer nicht gehabt hätten
und vielen vielen dank
jetzt als es dann eröffnet war und es
kamen besucher waren so erleichtert und
konnte anfangen das zu genießen ich
glaube ich habe den moment erst
angefangen dass alles was wir hier
gemacht haben zu genießen also dass
kesha auf immer wenn man fußball spielt
irgendwo beim sportler wenn du 20
gewünscht denn ich suche mir einen
hunger aber wenn der spannenden blick
bis zum schluss denn kochen dort damit
die emotionen viel höchst peinlich ist
bis zum schluss spannend sie
gut eineinhalb jahre sind seit der
eröffnung des tierparks vergangen
münchen
vor kurzem sind fünf waschbären dazu
gekommen
fallen ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da kommen sie schon tschechien und
abends wenn die letzten besucher nach
hause gegangen sind arbeiten die beiden
tiertrainer für einmal gemeinsam im neu
gebauten freiluft klassenzimmer
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
auch urs lee und miriam tormann hatten
ihre komfortzone verlassen und sind in
ein neues leben aufgebrochen
in andalusien betreiben sie die pferde
finca los angeles einen ort den
feriengäste nur ungern verlassen und
sich viele wollen wir das erreicht und
das runterfahren einfach wie eine große
familie wäre die nyt kellner und jetzt
frauen mit dem sophie haben jahr zu
einer hochzeit mit großem enthusiasmus
sind die beiden in ihr abenteuer
gestartet
doch die ernüchterung folgte schon bald
es war eine bewegte zeit auch mit ihnen
wollen wir noch mal zurück blicken
der 47 jährige hat einen
außergewöhnlichen job los steht im
dienst einer schwerreichen
unternehmerfamilie
er kümmert sich um deren häuser und
fahrzeugpark
heute muss er wie ip gäste abholen
[Musik]
doch schicke anzüge und fahrten mit
ps-starken edelkarossen gehören für us
bald der vergangenheit an denn sein herz
schlägt für richtige pferde
[Musik]
580 letztlich wie - pferdeexperten das
konzept besonders und so manch aber doch
offiziell zum verkauf einer beziehung
aufbauen
es ist ganz andere das als dass man
jetzt die letzten zehn jahre gemacht
habe was ich vorher gemacht da auf das
wirklich
[Musik]
ich habe das gar nicht vorstellen wie es
ist
das so weit weg für mich jetzt so wie
truck geringen wie es ist vor passte
sich lange vergangenheit bei der hufe
ein anderes zuhause ist teilt sich seine
freundin miriam tormann für ihren
arbeitstag
sie ist verkäuferin in einer
edelboutique satirischen minute zieht
schnell und spanien aktiv das ist ein
tragischer held es ja kübel und dann
glaubt durch ihn etwas vermindern
sache war daher wichtig folgen würde
schminke elf jahre lang hatte sie einen
treuen begleiter an ihrer seite den
belgischen schäferhund loben doch logo
kann nicht mit nach spanien
er muss hier in der schweiz bleiben
miriam und urspringen den schäferhund zu
mehr passierbar
das rentnerpaar kümmert sich seit jahren
um logo
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die spanische nicht mehr und so dafür
immer dasselbe muster abschied vor ihm
dass ich mich schon schwer krank sie hat
einfach zuerst die neue heimat von mirja
motors ist die pferde finger lausanne
grenze hier züchten und verkaufen die
auswanderer andalusischen rassepferde un
erteilen den feriengästen reitunterricht
us lebt bereits seit einigen wochen auf
dem hof und heute ist nun endlich auch
miriam angekommen
als erstes zeigt us ihren nachwuchs
[Musik]
dies ist ängstlich auf
ein mitarbeiter zeigt ihr was auf den
tisch kommt
da ist einfach so mit flucht und
feriengäste angestellte und die finca
chefs auf los angeles essen alle
zusammen beim frühstück bekommen die
reitschüler ihr pferd für den ausritt
zugeteilt die einteilung der pferde und
ehrgeiz ist natürlich chefsache
es geht darum was mit spezieller kennen
ja vieles ist neu für miriam vieles wird
sie lernen müssen
doch die größte herausforderung wird
sein ihren platz im team zu finden
ganz direkt
das ist immer böse
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also das jetzt genau so aktiv dass
läufer zwar nur langsam aber stetig die
beziehung zwischen miriam und robert
entspannt sich es kümmert sich auch um
den unterhalt des hofes die zäune sind
ihnen desolate im zustand
die angestellten haben die elektrischen
drähten nicht fachgerecht montiert jetzt
hat viel strom
[Musik]
ja sie sind lang und optisch einklagt
und wer wirklich zwischen nochmal ganz
wenige und logo und wenn möglich ein
innovativ sitze und ganz wenig zu machen
alles was ist mit drauf machen
schon als kind ist miriam geritten
[Musik]
jetzt kann sie ihre große erfahrung den
schülern weitergeben
[Musik]
miriams wissen ihr umgang mit pferden
und gästen beeindrucken auch robert
macht das möglich
die gäste etwas passiert was niemand
erwartet hat
ein pferd ist gestorben einfach so
[Musik]
kanada ist eine monarchie klubs geführt
mit der look mit der razzia bei die
links und rechts der herzschlag
in dem moment sehr schlimmes bei edith
erna sehr sehr ich leben ich selbst mag
sich nicht mit dem image einer
betriebsführung und wirklich im dümmsten
moment hat sich der laser klasse runter
[Musik]
geschäftspartner robert ist vor drei
tagen in die ferien gefahren
es will ihm den urlaub nicht verderben
und doch muss er eine sms mit der
traurigen nachricht schicken
[Musik]
herford
die habe ich mir das angeschaut werde
kaputt ging
also das wurde einfach nicht
das ganze geld denn die der situation
falsch dargestellt ich sie als ich mich
das richtige laufen auf der pferde finca
bemühen sich alle den betrieb möglichst
normal aufrecht zu erhalten
gäste sind da die reiten lernen wollen
[Musik]
und auch eine kaufinteressenten hat sich
angemeldet
ein feriengast hat sich während der
letzten ferien auf los angeles geradezu
in einen hengst verliebt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
barbara prammer und der andalucia
harmonieren perfekt gestütschef özkan
heute sein erstes pferd verkaufen
[Musik]
eine überglückliche frischgebackene
pferdebesitzerin und ein noch
glücklicherer pferde verkäufer
[Musik]
macht süchtig machen und es gibt so viel
zurück mit der ost sammer schaffen
mit soli bemüht doch haben wir hier
begeistert das gibt die soviel zurück
und das ist so intensiv wecke dass ich
sofort das ist die doppel herstellte und
das finde ich so schön und klar mit
allem so besprochen schwierigkeiten am
anfang habe ich mir die platz gefunden
hätte fast nie wirklich nie bereut
es dauerte wohl etwas länger als sie
gedacht hatten
nun aber haben miriam und durch ihren
platz in der neuen heimat gefunden
doch eine frage bleibt wer hat das sagen
auf der pferde finca
[Musik]
ueli familie ruckstuhl wollte schon
immer dass die kinder direkt vor der
haustüre spielen können und dass der
vater mehr zeit für die familie hat
[Musik]
die mutter träumte von einem garten und
in diesen hat nun sogar ein ganzes
gewächshaus platz ohne baubewilligung
[Musik]
will jetzt alles in der mache jetzt
gleich mal mit klimapolitik neues kommt
sie war dazu in jackson hole
[Musik]
familie ruckstuhl hat noch weitere pläne
sie will richtig sesshaft werden und ein
eigenes haus kaufen
zuerst aber schauen wir auch mit ihnen
zurück
[Applaus]
familie ruckstuhl verabschiedet sich auf
dem hof der eltern von markus im
thurgauischen egnach
machst du
da
scheiße
so ist
ja
adieu bradys winden elterliche hof der
familie immer wieder zu betonen da
machst du für mich zu vermitteln und zum
zweiten mal aus nach menton einem
kleinen ort in der nähe von kalgoorlie
der vater hat auf der gleichen form wie
bei der ersten auswanderung eine
anstellung bekommen und erneut konnte
die familie in ihr altes häuschen
einziehen
[Musik]
dieses paradies hatten sie einst
verlassen als sie erfuhren dass
josephine an einer lebensbedrohlichen
stoffwechselkrankheit leidet zur
behandlung der kleinen kehrte die
familie in die schweiz zurück die
behandlung eine
stammzellentransplantation verlief
erfolgreich doch hier mädchen muss ein
leben lang medizinisch betreut werden
es gibt ein leben vor der diagnose und
weiß nach der diagnose
[Musik]
jetzt geht's los los also die ware des
vormieters weg räumen
im keller treffen sie auch auf dinge die
sie einst bei ihrer überstürzten abreise
zurücklassen mussten
dort koste aber die wissenschaftler mit
dem fast nicht merkt immer vorbei
gelaufen was überhaupt auf hochtouren
der einzige weg sein
und auch wenn ihr neues zuhause nur
gemietet ist ihren garten dürfen sie um
flügen wie sie wollen und anbauen was
sie wollen
im großen stil eigenes gemüse
anzupflanzen
das war mit ein grund warum die familie
ausgewandert ist mit kuhdung frisch von
den rindern vor der haustür bereitet
markus das erste gemüsebeet vor und die
kleine josephine lernt dabei so wie alle
kinder lernen sie und ihren vater nach
josephine hat ihren ersten arzttermin in
der neuen heimat
die monatlichen untersuchungen finden
jeweils im spital von calgary statt
[Musik]
hallo schön dich wiederzusehen ist
gesund und gut aus so nun bin ich
gespannt wie alles gelaufen ist
die dancing hat es probleme gegeben
das herz ist gut die lungen sind gut die
leber die nieren
alles ist gut da war flüssigkeit in
ihrem gehirn
wir haben die schweizer ärzte gesagt
dass es behandelt werden muss sie haben
gesagt dass es auf dem jüngsten emily
besser ausschaut wenn du dich gerade so
wohl fühlt dann wollen wir dich doch
gleich untersuchen
ja ja ja wie eine prinzessin im krone
wie sich die organe und gelenke von
josephine längerfristig entwickeln
werden ist schwierig vorauszusagen
doch doktor kahn ist im moment zufrieden
zum glück gibt es keine herzprobleme
das ist echt ein großer vorteil mit dem
spitalbesuch ist der alltag in kanada
definitiv eingekehrt
juni
kompanie
sie selber geduldig bleibt es noch knapp
bei dem telefon
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie streben wir ein bisschen sehr
schnell ein arzt gesehen und wissen wer
ich bin und das ist was sie tony emmy k
das sieht mehr stücke sind die diagnose
necas moment lang reinartz gesehen oder
und einem schlagstock sowie noch ferien
wieder zurück an der arbeiterklasse
tiefland so nennt sich die gegend im
süden von alberta
sie ist bekannt für saftige steaks
[Musik]
tim story ist eine der wenigen bauern
der milchwirtschaft betreibt die familie
ruckstuhl hat drei kälber aufgenommen
markus will nun eine armen coo für die
jungtiere kaufen
die dort hinten aber wieviel willst doch
fuer sie haben 2008 rund 2800 das ist
viel geld
die 22 200
[Musik]
europas alena getan ist die roboter
nicht gemacht so deine tür zweite villa
im moment ja nach der premiere sicher
womit darum eine kompetente am tag in
geselliger fünfte liter am tag gehen als
kritikerin und erich menger fragt im
skoda mit hinaufgestiegen haben und das
ist ja so sie aber sicher ich leider es
globales problem
zwei fahrstunden von zu hause entfernt
ist markus mit 200 rindern unterwegs
angeführt von downloaden chef cowboy und
arbeitgeber von markus schreiben sie die
rinder auf die sommerweide krieg das
sind haltung
schweizer habe den ruf gute arbeit zu
sein meint markus ist so einer
die hochgelegenen sommerweiden gehören
dem staat pharma haben beide recht am
ziel das traditionelle pferderennen
[Musik]
jetzt sei ein abschluss burg gehört der
schnellste
das leben in ruckstuhl neue heimat ist
ein leben voller abwechslung giorgio
armani und josephine die wegen ihrer
krankheit große probleme mit den
gelenken und dem knochenbau hat hat hier
viel mehr möglichkeiten sich zu bewegen
so auch zu reiten
[Musik]
noch haben die eltern kein pony für die
kleine
dafür darf josef in ihren ersten ritt
auf einem der pferde von pharmachef
tullow machen ist sich knapp mit dem
geld geld die boni und diese worte haben
die zuschauer von auf und davon
derart berührt dass einige von ihnen
tatkräftig in das kanadische schicksal
von josephine eingegriffen haben
[Musik]
doch dazu später mehr
champions sowie warten schon alles dann
machen wir es so ich nehme ihn die da ja
beim training zu nutzen wissen fahrten
mag okay dann probieren wir das aus
lebst du hast ja alles schläft das 10
gewöhnliche haus schafe werden die
ersten sein die ihr können im freiluft
klassenzimmer vorführen
die creme für große und dann hätten sie
eigentlich zum schlachter solle
und dann haben wir uns der alexander eis
auf den geburtstag geschenkt münchen
minister denn und denn einmal gefunden
da brauchen wir noch mehr dazu und das
ist eigentlich der hintergedanke sie von
einer jury und seine zwei komplizen
haben alex anderen bremer nicht vor der
schlachtbank gerettet
sie lebten in einer auffangstation für
das dass die rettungsstation großen uni
eigentlich so kommt kein sind jetzt
extrem entspannt geht hier aber auch
alles klar
die muss waren sogenannte dauer hacker
also ladenhüter keiner wollte sie haben
[Musik]
dann steht jetzt nicht so ein masterplan
wo man sagt es kommen dies oder jenes
tier
es kommt immer darauf an welches gerade
zuhause sucht und die 3 die waren in der
auffangstation und ich glaube du hattest
sie gesehen und wir wollten eigentlich
nur ein greifvogel abholen
ja und schon sind die drei auch
eingezogen wenn der platz deshalb
hergibt und die zeit die wir halt jeden
tag auch für die tiere brauchen habakuk
gehabt oder haus champions mit jedem
tier wollen sie täglich trainieren
ich habe hier das wenn wir dann halt
machen das kind und luna unternehmen
alles wird nicht geklaut hier und da ein
wenig höher gestellt und springt rüber
und can't help bis zum 4
und doch ganz witzig obwohl sein flug
sind aber viele entscheider führen über
also der unterschied zwischen geist und
das ist schon schwierig
[Musik]
dent
und zurückkommen
[Musik]
seit über einem jahr lebt muss auf los
angeles neben dem reitbetrieb kümmert
sich der bauernsohn auch um die
landwirtschaft wegen feuergefahr muss er
eine brandschneise ins feld ziehen das
ist vorschrift in andalusien
[Musik]
so viel ab während der hochsaison sind
die tage auf der pferde finger lang und
die nächte kurz
miriam ist eine frühaufsteherin bevor
sie das frühstück auftischt träumt sie
die überbleibsel der letzten nacht weg
der frühe morgen ist der einzige moment
des tages den miriam für sich alleine
hat
das ist eine ganz geringe mengen die
teenies klickt es hingegen setzt auf
noch lange mit den gästen zusammen
doch auch er es bereits wieder auf den
beinen die fohlen brauchen ein
winterquartier samt koppel
denn bald schon werden sie von den
müttern getrennt robert lebt schon lange
in spanien
und hatte jahrelang einen eigenen
reitbetrieb auf diesen lernten sich die
beiden männer kennen fahrgast dann
freund aus freunden wurden
geschäftspartner die beiden beschlossen
zusammen eine finca zu übernehmen und
zur lieblingspolitiker
während andere prioritäten setzt und
daher natürlich das landwirtschaftliche
mechanische treppchen aber wenn ich nur
daran haben mit pferd damit rentiert wo
man gut berät die pferd ist also besser
das ist schon wichtig die landwirtschaft
um aber das einfach wirklich die
priorität sieht die wunderbare weise
[Musik]
noch hält robert mehr anteile an der
finca und fakt ist auch freundschaft
oder partnerschaft hin oder her
der alte pferdeflüsterer will noch das
sagen haben habe ich mich in ruhestand
[Musik]
in kanada sind die erntearbeiten beendet
drei lange monate haben sie gedauert
tags zuvor hatten die fahrer weiter noch
das letzte feld fertig gedreht heute ist
ein vorarbeiter ausgefallen
guten morgen markus übernimmt den job
und teilt die arbeiter ein
wir bringen die erntemaschinen zu
erfahren zurück und dann reinigen wir
sie
[Musik]
ja wenn jemand anders stimmen ist er
aber herr fischer genau weniger
organisieren aber dampf machen
du kannst an der spitze fahren nein ich
mache das schlusslicht
[Musik]
jetzt müssen die geleasten mähdrescher
zu fahren zurück
dort werden sie gereinigt und einmal
sauber wieder dem landmaschinenhändler
übergeben
[Applaus]
dieser lastwagen war geladen da wieder
rauskommt
ja der braucht einen rechten stoß
[Musik]
eigentlich ist markus heute für das vieh
zuständig rinder welchen sogenannten
feed lot of dawn los form gemästet
wurden gehen zum besitzer zurück
[Musik]
brauchst du einen zähler
da sind die anarchie
also will in diesem sommer auf der weide
kontaktleute mal darauf da eine mörderin
im tatort mit dem titel natur
doch ob fan oder wild einmal 750 kilo
schwer er alt alle rinder das gleiche
schicksal
sie landen beim metzger
[Musik]
ja alles gut ist jetzt ja das küchenteam
im tierpark bell ist gut eingespielt ja
also mittlerweile schon lang immer zu
wissen und so über anderthalb jahre
schaffen
und da man immer wieder alles so viele
sachen wiederholen sich wieder und dann
kann ich gut mit ihnen spazieren
kaum war der tierpark eröffnet erfuhren
alexandra und remo dass sie bald eltern
würden
ich denke dass labour wunder da hat das
wird prägend sie also eine mobile wochen
zwischen die tier leben fast und ein
großer spielplatz von einem herrlich
ideal also schauen wir mal ob seite man
die punkte support und warte ich immer
nicht etwa zu vermachen dem idee her ist
das macht ist das nicht sagen wir geben
zu hause ein bisschen mehr hatten oder
ob marie alexandra zu heben die hunde
trainiert jetzt übernimmt sie den
kleinen remo wird in der tiger arena
erwartet und der neue star in der manege
ist timon ein stubentiger aus dem katzen
heim
beim dreh dich simon ammann hat okay
jetzt war es gut jetzt gehen wir nach
vorn so allmer slalom laufen
das heißt sie gut gemacht ja habe ich
mit dem großen tiger auch schon probiert
hat nicht funktioniert
da ist das große leckerli und tschüss
will der gleiche los wie ein großer
punkt gemacht alles gut kommt alle und
aufbauzeit zeigt wie groß du bist mach
das mal hier und da sieht man nämlich
wie groß die sibirische tiger ist gutes
mädchen ja gut gemacht es waren mitunter
die tiger die remo zum auswandern
bewogen hatten
der 36-jährige hatte die schweiz
verlassen um sich eine eigene welt zu
erschaffen
dort sind zum beispiel wo im olympischen
spiele sind christa schweizer fernsehen
oder wohlgemerkt okay du bist im anderen
land so sei aber wirklich so dass man
halt meistens doppelt im park sind
das ist jetzt so ist es und da ist es
egal ob deutschland oder der schweiz ist
sondern dass ich dies mit händen zu
greifen der kunden sowie das die richter
machen und wir sagen nicht erzählen wie
stores sowie zimmern organe kann
auch in spanien findet es kaum zeit die
gegend außerhalb der finger zu erkunden
selbst ein bad im pool hat der 49
jährige noch nie genommen
viel arbeit zwar doch diese zahlt sich
auszuzeichnen bis jetzt im herbst so gut
durchdacht
das ist eine steigerung große steige die
verbraucher warten wir also über
derartige mittel sogar zu chinas bahnhof
sie ist ruhig sie braucht keine
beruhigungsspritze wenn man da ist sind
alle pferde ruhig nicht alle aber einige
gute schule spanisch zeit für einige
momente hatten die beiden während der
hochsaison kam diese zweisamkeit kiefer
mist vor allem englischsprachige coffee
menge spaß das haben wir im moment jetzt
wo es ist allerdings liegt anteilsmässig
menschen ich hoffe mit liefern
mit speziellen des mexikanischen monate
das gutgeht damals noch das und das
schätzen viele die schon direkt sprach
jetzt intensive sprach und um dem staat
ist irgendwie normal aussieht dass mich
das sehr geschätzt
dank gestohlen
[Musik]
die geringe regel nimmt alexandra an den
aktivitäten in einen teil der ort bietet
vieles für ihre mädchen zum beispiel
lesenachmittage solche tätigkeiten
helfen josephine ihr gesundheitszustand
ist stabil und entwickelt sich gut
für die vierjährige ist es wichtig dass
sie auf jede mögliche weise gefördert
wird
seit gut einem halben jahr bekommt sie
nun auch ergo und physiotherapie die
vortritt und denke das funktioniert so
denn es ist sowieso habe der therapeutin
der meeresspiegel ist machbar das ist
gut und sie genau jeden tag wenn es das
wetter zu erlauben sie auf dem
spielplatz so witzig anhänger
[Musik]
speziellen sprachunterricht erteilt dir
die lehrerin miss alles sprechen wird
immer besser seit ich mit ihr arbeiten
anfänglich war sie eher zurückhaltend
nun aber ist die teil der klasse spielt
und redet mit allen und sie ist immer
bereit neues auszuprobieren
mit
[Musik]
nicht weggehen wollte ich noch die
anderen tiere machen
greven start ins leben verlief
reibungslos es war eine hausgeburt er
kam im kleinen häuschen mitten im park
zur welt der kleine muck lied genießt
ganz besondere freiheiten
konkret heißt das zum beispiel dass er
bei uns ohne windeln auch wächst und das
kann auch sehr gut klappen und ich finde
es ganz toll zu sehen wie gut man auch
mit kleinen kindern kommunizieren kann
manchmal ist es wie eine intuition und
manchmal zeigt das ganz deutlich und das
ist genauso wie man irgendwann weiß das
kind ist durstig oder das kind möchte
schlafen genauso weiß man dann das kind
muss jetzt mal
sie hält sich sehr viele gedanken
gemacht und drin und alles und ist
interessanter junger mann kriegt ein
hundewelpe später kam mit zwei wochen
stubenrein
also warum zu stemmen der wind günstig
ganz natürlich auch noch was machst du
hier auf dem weg also saß auf der bank
die relativ schnell
total
[Musik]
remo geht nicht dass bittsteller zur
bank nein ganz im gegenteil
das geschäft läuft hervorragend und
übertrifft die erwartungen
25.000 stadt erhofften 15.000 besucher
kamen im ersten jahr und mittlerweile
ist die bank kunde bei ihm dürfen ab und
zu mit einer von der bank schöne ist
dass hier unheimlich viel alles machen
und deswegen ist sehr wichtig um das war
die idee so was wie innen bringen
jetzt werde man das ja im winter zum
ersten mal zur dinnershow anbieter mit
vier-gang-menü und show aber nun ist er
ohne tieren
[Musik]
die auswanderung hat der familie
ruckstuhl glück gebracht
[Musik]
das schicksal der kleinen josephine hat
viele zuschauer von auf und davon
berührt und sie wollten das mädchen
unterstützen
[Musik]
es sind ganz viele privatpersonen herab
schreiber und zeitrahmen möchtest dass
vieles boni sinken so und den autor zu
fahren oder blick hätte seine wunsch
rubrik den winter was auch immer und
dann haben wir den anblick
ich finds alles während die sich hinter
nehmen wir mal särge cisco die harmonie
haben gelernt ein dritter die händler im
vollbild fremd das pferdchen hat knapp
3000 franken gekostet
[Musik]
das restliche geld haben die eltern in
einem college fonds für die mädchen
angelegt
[Musik]
erst darüber
doch jeder
[Musik]
bis zum 3 geschenkt und mich sind
dankbar
[Musik]
auf los angeles bieten die finger
betreiber ihren gästen immer wieder
etwas neues
heute wollen sie eine spezielle wright
formation auf dem freien feld einüben
alle reiseguides gehen mit für miriam
und uns eine willkommene gelegenheit um
endlich wieder einmal gemeinsam
unterwegs zu sein
[Musik]
mussten abschnitte die crysis zu ihren
cappuccino sich durchsetzen zu können
das war wohl miriams größte
herausforderung im neuen leben
hier darf ich du das neue leben gab
miriam die chance sich
weiterzuentwickeln
sie hat dann selbstvertrauen und innere
stärke gewonnen
auch uns hat neue seiten an sich
entdeckt seine aufmerksamkeit gilt
lalita lalita ist das sorgenkind auf dem
hof bei einem ausritt erschrak die stute
derart dass sie kaum mehr in der gruppe
reiten kann und immer nervös ist unser
kunde dass ich weiß nicht wieso aber das
ruhige weltkrieg haben
das ist das war ja oft auch sehr gern
machen probiere mettler dass sie ruhig
blieben aber ich glaube schon
auch nicht zum beispiel worden sein
[Musik]
hallo hallo und als muss die kleine
ableger du wirst dich gebracht und
mustafi der schläfchen software jetzt
kann ich im moment mal kurz aus remus
plan scheint aufzugehen
ja ich habe den das wird jetzt
bankintern schön verteilt flyer und
damit das schon funktionieren kann ich
dir königshaus okay doch das
kerngeschäft bleiben natürlich die tiere
und ihre darbietungen
ob groß oder klein die besucher sollen
immer wieder von neuem überrascht werden
[Musik]
so wird raten trotzdem in unserem wald
hin weil egal bei welchem wetter unsere
vögel wollen natürlich fliegen so weit
bei unserer kg regisseur die kommt aus
einer auffangstation die konnte nicht
richtig fliegen
ich musste es einfach alles noch so ein
bisschen lernen man sieht sie
kalifornien an der brust ob alles in
ordnung ist das ist es bei ihr geld das
sie mal los ja da hast du dich zu lange
festgehalten karriere ich so ein
bisschen stoße dann geht es ein bisschen
zu fuß gehen geld genau ich habe nachher
noch eine da sieht man dann den
unterschied wenn so ein tier richtig
fliegen kann
der bus hat wurde vermutlich von einem
auto angefahren
zwei christen gesehen noch immer ist ein
flügel lädiert geht ruckzuck hier bei
ihr
[Musik]
jetzt da die ernte eingebracht ist hat
familie ruckstuhl zeit für kleine
ausflüge in der umgebung ja ob von
mediathek eine anders gestaltete da
stressfrei jetzt gestalt ist mir ein
sich von weniger stress da hast du hast
auch das letzte drittel hat mich hinten
zu verlagern oder was weiß ich einen
schrei
[Musik]
wir sind zufrieden da jedes kleine
drachen erfüllen
pit trautner wird doch statt
der traum den sie mit nach kanada nehmen
ist ein eigenes haus mit viel umschwung
zu besitzen in champion 35 minuten von
wänden entfernt könnte dieser traum
endlich in erfüllung gehen
sie schauen sich ein erstes haus mit
rund acht hektar umschwung an
[Musik]
noch ein tipp durch schicke dir über
elena
[Musik]
mehr als 80 jahre und 390 also günstig
aber dafür seien beide häuser weiß alt
und
schwierigste sei dank
[Musik]
ja
elena seelow
[Musik]
wer alles dann buht mayor
plastikschlaufe machen
das signal die maschine also glaubt
irgendwann aber die stets weit weg von
mir wäre es wichtig das kind am liebsten
anthony stewart findet andere distrikt
so je nach strecke das sind ja ich
glaube wir haben es gesehen wir sind
zuversichtlich was nervenenden wir uns
schon lieber ja aber wir könnten auch
damit leben
es war eine 30 minütige fahrt 29 nein
das waren bestimmt 30 minuten bestimmt
familie ruckstuhl schaut sich noch
einige grundstücke an
sicher ist im riesigen kanada werden sie
irgendwann etwas finden
[Musik]
einmal seite an seite über das frisch
gemähte feld reiten das wäre in der
schweiz kaum möglich
[Musik]
er schlägt dem fass
das spiel aufzogen
david davidoff
[Musik]
für mich erklärt dass sie ähnlich viele
ruhige privat weniger auf gefühlt habe
ist mir wirklich mühe damit aber nicht
sagen
der ganztag für sich selbst gemacht und
mir geschafft und dabei für sich selber
vor allem das ist genau das was ich mir
vorgestellt
zusammen mit dem see und das gestorben
wie traum leben
[Musik]
das gebäck
auch renault hat sein schicksal in die
eigenen hände genommen
mit großem elan und unerschöpflichen
ideenreichtum bringt er seinen tierpark
voran johannes übernachtungs special
ich denke nur ein paar kallay machen
dass er ist unheimlich schwierig
außerdem so riesig und darum probieren
überall andere stammplatz finden wo
weiter unabhängig sind will heißen
schlechter und schlechter vorliegt dann
fällt das geld also muss das abdecken
mit anderen sache das ist ein richtig
klein abendflug peter in riems und
alexandra spark sind auch die tiere
immer wieder gefordert publikumsliebling
marek muss eine neue flugroute einüben
[Musik]
und grund super bei mir
das verfahren vereint sie zurückkommt
[Musik]
mehr
er war sehr gut
jawohl
klasse gut geld sprich widerrufen
heute feiert so schön geht doch dass
fragen mit den häusern soll das macht es
irgendwie perfekt
die sieht von weitem gleich schön ist
wirklich schön dass man jetzt da sind
und alle quasi heimisch wurde sind ja
das schöne ist dass wir jetzt nicht nur
zusammenarbeiten sondern wirklich auch
eine familie sind es total herrlich sich
auch so noch mal kennen zu lernen wenn
man einfach mal wirklich zusammen lebt
und nicht nur arbeiten auf die distanz
versucht was aufzubauen
und jetzt können wir wirklich geniessen
was wir in den letzten jahren geschuftet
haben also sehe ich das langsam kommt
auch der ausblick da ich fast
unbezahlbar ja und wenn dann irgendwann
mal würde schließlich doch vom balkon 70
aus und der usa
denn wäre das schön sie auch irgendwann
wenn wir nicht umfallen zum essen sind
noch immer darunter genau und jedes jahr
aufs neue gibt es schweizerinnen und
schweizer die ihren träumen folgen
wir kommen morgen einige von ihnen
werden wir dabei begleiten
[Musik]
patricia und ihr mann romano kehren den
alltag den rücken
auf der insel bali übernehmen sie ein
kleines gäste aus doch der zustand des
hauses ist schlecht
[Musik]
sie investieren viel geld und herzblut
in die renovierung doch die gäste
bleiben aus
bestellt
[Musik]
vergessen ist der hochzeitskleider und
familie volk gründet in kanada ein
holzfäller unternehmen mit im gepäck
zwei monströse holzernte maschinen
in der neuen heimat angekommen folgt
rasch der erste schock christians
geschäft läuft an
doch seine frau simone plagt das heimweh
und auf und davon richtung fuerteventura
[Musik]
mit ihrem alten auto und 30000 franken
auf dem konto wandern tobias bayer und
michael paris aus in einem
einkaufszentrum wollen sie eine bar
eröffnen aber der ausbau verzögert sich
und auch die suche nach einer wohnung
macht probleme
ich habe nur in bahrain geschaut da
würde ich auf keinen fall wollen auf und
davon geht weiter die neue staffel ab
dem 6 januar um 21 uhr auf sf1
[Musik]
huf und infos präsentiert wurde der
leyen für oliver längert oder weniger
lang weg sind